Since Apex Legends launched in 2019, the
Respawn team has added a tonne to the game:
new legends, maps, abilities, lore,
you name it. With so much to dig into,
here are 9 things you might
not know about Apex Legends.
Octane, the high-energy, death-defying stuntman
was first added back in season one of Apex,
but you might not know that his origins actually
lie in the Titanfall 2 speedrunning community.
If you played Titanfall 2, you might remember
its Gauntlet: a replayable tutorial area with
a tantalizing leaderboard that just begged you to
try it over and over again. Cash Mayo rose to the
challenge, completing the Gauntlet in 12 seconds
flat by using frag grenades to give themself
a speed boost. The team at Respawn were
clearly impressed, and incorporated this into
Octane’s stuntman backstory: he set the course
record on the Gauntlet by using a grenade to
propel himself across the finish line, resulting
in him losing both legs. And if you’re wondering
if Cash Mayo’s 12-second Gauntlet record still
stands, it doesn’t. Cash Mayo has now managed to
complete the feat in a little over 10 seconds.
If there’s one thing I know about Mirage,
it’s that he loves pork chops. So much so, in
fact, that his recipe is included on one of the
game’s loading screens. Andrew Rea, more commonly
known for his YouTube series Binging With Babish,
made Mirage’s pork chops exactly how the recipe
calls for, adding 15 GRAMS of ground cloves and an
additional 15 grams of ground cinnamon. It doesn’t
just taste like cloves, it burns like cloves.
Turns out that Manny Hagopian, the
writer responsible for Mirage’s recipe
made a slight error when converting
the recipe to the metric system.
Manny came up with a revised recipe, which
Babish made and gave his seal of approval to.
Mirage isn’t the only Legend with a go-to recipe,
Lifeline’s cookies and Mad Maggie’s Warrior Feast
are also both supposed to be delicious.
Back in 2020, Respawn ran the , and one of the
limited-time modes let you play the game in 3rd
person. While the mode was short-lived, you can
still play in the third person in the firing range
just by following some simple steps. The elephant
in the room with Apex is that it’s made by the
Titanfall team, it’s set in the same universe
as Titanfall, some characters and loadouts are
even FROM Titanfall, so how come there are no
Titans in the game? Well, the Apex team has
tried to add them to the game multiple times
internally, but the Titans cause balance issues
that the team hasn’t found the right solution to,
like how do you make a battle royale map suitable
for the giant Titans? How do you account for the
Titans’ vast health pool? While the team
has gone on record to say never say never
with regard to adding them to the game, they’re
not on the roadmap right now. So Titans may not
have made it to Apex, but plenty of characters
from the Titanfall games have. Honestly, I could
make a whole video about these connections, but
here are some key ones you might have missed.
Valkyrie, for example, is the daughter
of Viper, you may remember him
as being the pilot of the jerk Titan
that ripped off BT’s arm in Titanfall 2.
Valkyrie, real name Kairi Imahara, even
had fellow legend Rampart use the flight
core from her dad’s Titan to make the
jetpack she uses for the Apex Games. v
Mirage is the nephew of Droz, who
helped Cooper and BT hijack the IMS
Malta and provided covering fire when
Cooper went head to head with Viper.
Three Legends were previously
Titan pilots: Wraith,
Ash, and Newcastle. While technically
Valkyrie has piloted a titan before,
she didn’t complete her training to become
a fully-fledged pilot. Octane owns a Titan,
but he isn’t a pilot. He just keeps one
covered in graffiti in his massive house.
Wraith isn’t from the Titanfall games,
but she’s got a cool link to the Titanfall
games nonetheless. She’s from an alternate
dimension where the bad guys from Titanfall 2
actually won–this ties into her in-game abilities
to be able to hear warning voices, which are her
from other dimensions, and of course, her ability
to use a dimensional rift to get out of trouble.
While there are obviously many Titanfall
Easter Eggs to enjoy in Apex Legends,
references to other games are hidden throughout.
For example, Wattson’s Strange Attractor skin
is clearly a reference to Samus from
Metroid, even down to the teal bracers
mimicking Samus’ arm canon. Crypto’s Devil’s
Advocate skin, is a Devil May Cry reference,
with the red coat and black shirt looking
a hell of a lot like Dante’s usual get up.
Pathfinder has a banner pose called “For the
Birds”, where he gets attacked by a raven,
clearly an ode to Overwatch’s Bastion,
who has a bird friend named Ganymede.
It even translates to weapons: the Mastiff
has a legendary skin called “Warp Zone”,
the name itself is a reference to shortcuts
from Super Mario Bros, but the skin is
teeming with references to video games, from NES
buttons and cartridge slot to a USB connector,
and a little screen - while this character
looks like a little Mega Man, it was actually
confirmed by Apex Senior Producer Josh Medina to
be pixel Jack Cooper from Titan Toons, a Titanfall
cartoon series made by Respawn animator Moy Parra.
Back at the 2019 Game Awards, Mirage appeared in a
“video call” with host Geoff Keighley to announce
that year’s Winter Event: Mirage’s Holo-Day Bash.
While it may have looked like it was
pre-recorded and made specifically for the show,
it was actually done live. Mirage’s actor Roger
Craig Smith was decked in a performance capture
outfit and was speaking to Geoff who was on stage
at the Microsoft Theatre across the street. The
stunt was a collaboration between Respawn and
a creative technology studio called the Mill,
where they utilised real-time rendered shooting
tech to shoot and animate the skit. Here’s a
weird one that you might not know: many of the
Legends may look spry and energetic, but several
of them are over one hundred years old. Horizon
for example is 37, but she was trapped in a black
hole for a few decades, making her roughly 125
years old. Ash is 121 and also spent a few years
with her head shattered in another dimension,
but that’s a story for a different video,
and Revenant is an astonishing 313. The
youngest legend is Rampart, she’s only 21.
Okay, this one’s cheating because it’s a
Titanfall easter egg, but an Apex dev helped
bring it to light, so I’m counting it. A Titanfall
2 Easter Egg went unnoticed for over five years
until Respawn’s Narrative Historian David Bartle
dropped a couple of hints on his Twitter account
as to its location. Turns out in Titanfall 2’s
infamous time travelling Effect and Cause mission,
if you time swapped eighty-eight times outside a
certain door, the room changes into a… weird one
where a dead soldier’s body lies on the floor,
while another is …doing the splits between two
kitchen countertops. Definitely a bit of a
weird one, but one that remained hidden for
an awfully long time. It was the creation
of Respawn senior designer Jake Keating.
So there you have it, 9 things you may not
know about Apex Legends. For more on the game,
make sure you check out Jordan’s weekly
column Hot Drop over on GameSpot.com,
or subscribe to the channel for more features like
this one. If you’ve got any Apex tidbits, drop
them in the comments below, or come find me on
Twitter, I’m @lucyjamesgames. Catch ya next time.